[Musica]
allora anni universitari cina 2000 2007
non volevo dire la data perché sono
troppo vecchio per ok mi preparo per
quello che sarà uno dei viaggi che
ricorderò per tutta la vita ovvero
migliorare la conoscenza della lingua
cinese già lì insomma abbastanza
difficile e
conoscere appieno la loro cultura parto
con due preconcetti però mentre sto
facendo la valigia come a milano il
primo è che
mangerò quasi esclusivamente i prodotti
tipici che però non riscontriamo qua in
italia nei ristoranti cinesi ovvero gli
involtini primavera i ravioli
bellissimo preconcetto però rende un po
l'idea la seconda invece che ci saranno
prodotti contraffatti
torno dopo più o meno tre mesi e in
effetti a pro valigia mi rendo conto che
avevo comprato dei prodotti che non
erano per niente contraffatti anzi erano
fatti da delle donne cinesi che hanno
dedicato tutta la loro vita a produrre
vestiti vestaglie magliette insomma e
quindi questo è sicuramente è stato un
motivo di orgoglio la seconda invece che
credetemi anche se non mi conoscete ma
ho mangiato di tutto magari chi è stato
in cina lo può confermare ma non ho mai
ha mangiato un involtino primavera
un raviolo eccetera poi questo perché in
effetti la la cucina cinese è una delle
più variegate nel mondo e comunque anche
a un grande influenza anche su tutte le
regioni all'interno ovviamente sempre
del panorama cinese quindi questo per
dirvi che in effetti così come tutti noi
preparatevi che da qui in poi le slide
saranno bruttissimi quindi cercherò di
concentrare la mia personalità come come
speaker sempre se sarò all'altezza
tutto questo per dirvi che in realtà
sono partito con questi preconcetti che
poi si sono tradotti e sono
fondamentalmente degli stereotipi ora
immagino che ognuno di voi in sala
quando voleva partire è partito per un
viaggio con amici parenti famiglia
marito moglie eccetera
e chiaro che aveva o ha comunque avuto
degli stereotipi nella propria testa
no stereotipi legati come nel mio caso
il cibo stereotipi legati magari una
determinata cultura magari a determinati
persone che avrà incontrato eccetera
quindi io personalmente in questo non mi
sono vergognato perché in effetti più o
meno gli stereotipi sono dappertutto
che cosa sono però gli stereotipi belle
stereotipi vi faccio degli esempi anche
se insomma sui miei sulla mia pelle gli
ho abbastanza vissuti quindi insomma
sono abbastanza semplici gli italiani
mangiano gli spaghetti questo è un
classico stereotipo
piuttosto che i tedeschi
amano indossare i calzini bianchi e
le i sandali le donne non sanno guidare
qui chiedo venia le donne ma in realtà è
un puro e semplice esempio scusate mi
serve per il ragionamento finale poi
capirete
ultimo ma non meno importante sono i
videogame videogame sono per noi
ragazzini no quelli che si chiudono i
nerd che si chiudono nelle stanze
giocano
chiudono le tapparelle non hanno
contatti pieni di brufoli so
estremizzando mi sono lasciato un po
andare però è per rendere il di anche
perché io sono un amante di videogiochi
non sono un ragazzino però magari finito
questo specie torna a casa bassole e le
tapparelle tende rho giocare mi farò
crescere anche qualche brufolo perché
però gli stereotipi sono così radicati
allora lo stereotipo in effetti è
comunque un'idea un preconcetto che una
persona un gruppo di persone può avere
nei confronti di una società o comunque
di anche di altri individui pensate
anche agli stereotipi che noi abbiamo in
italia tra nord e sud non sono banali
sussistono e ci sono ancora perché però
sono così radicati perché
fondamentalmente fanno parte vivono
sussistono sono anche nati all'interno
di una determinata cultura quindi va da
sé che effettivamente sono molto molto
radicati e per poterli cambiare
in effetti bisognerebbe anche cambiare
un po la cultura anche se io
personalmente non sono assolutamente
d'accordo perché anche se un indomani un
popolo volesse cambiare la propria
cultura sempre se è possibile e mi rendo
conto che non è così non è detto che gli
stereotipi
finiranno comunque si verranno eliminati
anzi in realtà continueranno ad esserci
come ad oggi ecco perché dicevo delle
slide allora in questo in tutto questo
c'è un altro tassello molto importante
che invece
è legato alla pubblicità la pubblicità
in effetti comunque veicolo allo
stereotipo in qualche modo lo veicola
anche in modo abbastanza invisibile però
tende comunque a veicolarlo e nello
stesso tempo comunque la pubblicità è
influenzata anche molto da quella che è
la cultura quindi stiamo parlando di
stereotipi cultura e pubblicità
immaginatevi giusto per farvi capire che
la pubblicità influenzata molto dalla
cultura
immaginatevi una pubblicità coreana sta
coreano la pubblicità ne troverete anche
su youtube se non l'avete mai vista
tendenzialmente molto vivace e piena di
colori molto molto allegra la maggior
parte delle volte chiaramente sto
generalizzando
immaginate allora invece di trasportarla
all'interno di un panorama italiana di
un'audi una famiglia italiana o che
comunque vive in italia mentre sta
ascoltando o se sta vedendo il tg
il tg il telegiornale e tra una notizia
brutta e un'altra altrettanto brutta se
non peggio perché di questo purtroppo in
questo periodo stiamo vivendo c'è il
break pubblicitario e c'è la pubblicità
coreana è chiaro che la famiglia inizia
comunque
c'è un certo stupore che può tradursi
uno stupore positivo o negativo ma
comunque c'è questo per farvi capire
effettivamente che la pubblicità ha un
ruolo molto importante anche per
veicolare lo stereotipo
in tutto questo se parliamo di
pubblicità
a me viene in mente sicuramente la
televisione che ha influenzato e un mass
media per eccellenza che influenza i
comportamenti delle persone però giusto
anche quello che ha detto poco fa
federico qual è quali sono le
piattaforme che influenzano giorno per
giorno un minuto per minuto addirittura
anche secondo perché se non apriamo il
nostro cellulare chiaramente li troviamo
e siamo condizionati sono i social media
facciamo un esempio un esempio tik tok
giusto perché appunto cousins a pennello
rispetto a quello che ha detto poco fa
federico tik tok è nella sua grande
ascesa ha lanciato un formato che si
chiama l'ashtag challenge quindi i brand
sono in grado di ingaggiare milioni di
persone per fare dei balletti ora non vi
chiedo chi di voi si è già cimentato io
l'ho fatto con bruttissime figure però
in effetti in effetti funzionano molto
molto bene
quindi stiamo dicendo che il social per
come l'immaginario chiaramente potrebbe
essere uno stereotipo
sono una forma di comunicazione libera
dove non ci sono sussistono gli
stereotipi non ci sono beh in realtà non
è proprio così perché secondo una
ricerca condotta da un istituto dove non
pronuncia il nome ma non per motivi di
privacy ma perché è talmente troppo
lunga non mi ricordo è emerso che hanno
prelevato un campione di oltre mille
annunci su facebook su tre importanti
nazioni che sono il brasile e gli stati
uniti e il regno unito con i tre culture
completamente diverse però c'era un
fattore comune che tutti e tre
utilizzavano lo stereotipo quindi in
realtà allo stereotipo comunque c'è
anche nel sociale perché c'è ovviamente
all'interno di una determinata cultura
quali sono stati gli insetti più
interessanti le donne sono più
rappresentati con abiti e rivelatori
quindi questo è già un tema molto
importante la seconda che gli uomini
sono considerati più arrivisti in questi
annunci video che hanno che hanno preso
in considerazione quindi più tendenti
anche alla carriera questo vuol dire che
le donne non lo sono però quello che mi
ha colpito di più fino a un certo punto
poi è quello che sono stati gli episodi
o meglio gli stereotipi razziali quelli
di razza di genere perché in effetti le
persone disabili le persone di colore e
le persone ispaniche hanno meno
probabilità di essere viste perché sono
rappresentate chiaramente meno rispetto
invece a tutte le altre persone quindi è
chiaro che fondamentalmente stiamo
dicendo che i social comunque non sono
liberi a volte di comunicare un brand
che entra sui social vuole comunicare a
volte deve tenere conto di questo
stereotipo perché in effetti è proprio
così ora arriviamo all'altro lato del
discorso lo stereotipo delle campagne
pubblicitarie e sempre comunque un male
cioè i brand oggi se utilizzano uno
stereotipo fanno sempre male oppure
invece possono avere ragione e chiaro
che se guardiamo gli stereotipi di razza
di genere assolutamente non c'è niente
da dire fanno comunque sempre male non
ci sono ragionamenti da da concludere è
sempre comunque un male però ci sono
degli stereotipi che io definisco
stereotipi neutri sterrati piene e utili
per me ho coniato questo termine sono
degli stereotipi che tendenzialmente non
dovrebbero ledere l'attività di una
persona facciamo un esempio
lele i giapponesi
ok sono molto bravi a fare le foto
stereotipo proprio diciamo banalissimo
gli austriaci sono molto bravi in a
riprodurre musica classica proprio per
quello che è la loro storia gli olandesi
magari sono lentigginosi irlandesi sono
molto bravi a bere la birra nei locali e
gli italiani sempre noi ci siamo ci
siamo in mezzo ovviamente io
sottoscritto oppure italiano a mano
gesticolare mi sono un po contenuto oggi
mangiano la pizza e suonano il mandolino
che poi non so dalla vostra esperienza
io non ho mai visto un italiano a
suonare il mandolino però sono poi
questo è sono sono veramente punti di
vista suoniamo tutti gli strumenti a
parte a parte il mandolino e quindi in
un certo senso
se i brand e lavorano su questi
tipologie di stereotipi che sono
definiti neutri
fondamentalmente
possono parlare a più audience se invece
non parlano questi stereotipi rischiano
comunque di escludere una grande parte
importante ora
leggiamo questa frase anzi questa parola
scusate che si chiama automobile e
quanti di voi per alzata di mano
l'associano al sesso maschile non c'è
una risposta né giusta né sbagliati non
c'è in questo caso un alzata di mano né
giusta né sbagliata quanti di voi
associano al sesso maschile la parola
automobile
non dovete pensare l'esercizio a non
pensate a la tipologia di auto cioè non
pensate a un brand rispetto a un altro
home page è proprio così distinto
nessuno non ci credo bravi so che state
facendo il lavoro di speed game tipo che
guardo chi va avanti nelle lastre di
vetro non so se l'avete visto bravissimo
ti stimo ma non ti stimo perché
ovviamente hai detto del sesso maschile
ma perché è alzato la mano e insomma mi
conforta ma semplicemente perché in una
mia esperienza pregressa
ho dovuto gestire una campagna nel mondo
automotive
non vi dico ovviamente il brand non
avevo dati a supporto e quindi sono
partito da un presupposto veicolare gran
parte del mio budget che aveva a
disposizione solo esclusivamente su
facebook su un target maschile over 40
alto spendente in realtà i dati hanno
sfidato lo stereotipo post campagna
perché le maggiori converter appunto
bravissime
erano le donne sempre over 40 quindi
quello che ho fatto e raccogliere i dati
e lavorare su una seconda web di
campagna sia un secondo flight dove
chiaramente sono riuscito a spalmare il
budget da una parte su quelle che erano
la percentuale di persone quindi del
sesso femminile che sa che erano più
converter è come converte intendo
persone che erano potenzialmente
interessate a quella vettura per
ricevere un preventivo è invece una
piccola parte di budget di budget e di
comunicazione lo destinato sicuramente
al sesso maschile sempre over 40 è un
puro esempio
quindi stiamo dicendo che effettivamente
su quelli che sono gli stereotipi neutri
i brand oggi dovrebbero comunque
lavorare perché hanno tanti dati a
disposizione che poi magari non le sanno
usare questo sicuramente è un altro tema
ma non è questa la sede è chiaro che i
brand oggi possono e devono lavorare su
una mole di dati che hanno a
disposizione per creare quelle che sono
definite le baire personas e bella
persona sono per chi non lo sa delle
persone
astratti in un certo senso però che
trovano supporto da un dato che i punti
brand dovrebbero avere in casa e sono di
svariate tipologie potrebbero essere
bailey personas che si differenziano non
tanto per il sesso ma per l'età oppure
per gli interessi oppure per le passioni
che possono avere
vi faccio un esempio insomma sto andando
avanti ad esempio ma perché mi aiutano e
penso che aiutino anche voglia capire
quello che voglio dire sempre parlando
di stereotipi neutri e di buyer
personaggio immaginatevi che c'è un
nuovo brand nel mondo della birra che
vuole lanciare un nuovo prodotto un
nuovo prodotto una birra innovativa
insomma che dal gusto originale rispetto
a tutti gli altri ora il lavoro che
potrebbe fare questo brand e creare due
bayern personali differenti
la prima che è quella dove costruirà una
bayern persona legata più a al concetto
di stereotipo non so mi viene in mente
un uomo over 50 single sto immaginando
che ama andare a tutti gli effetti e le
feste dove ovviamente il tema è l'alcol
per esempio l'october fest
che è un esempio insomma abbastanza
facile da considerando il boccale di
birra e ama grigliare con gli amici
quindi me l'immagine che sta grigliando
intanto tra un costata e l'altra
sorseggia una una bevanda la bevanda
appunto dalla birra e dall'altra parte
invece l'altra bayern personas che è
fuori dagli schemi almeno per come sono
abituato immaginare che è una persona
over 60 donna
che accudisce cinque nipoti insomma
povera lei però insomma
è una bayern persona che frequenta
lezioni di tango e tra un insomma un
passo e l'altro a ma comunque
sorseggiare un buon bicchiere di birra
ora la prima bayern per suns che si
fonda sullo stereotipo facciamo finta
che però abbia dei dati sotto per poter
giustificare questo mentre la seconda
sarà una bella persona non stereotipata
perché chiaramente nell'immaginario di
questo brand non c'è uno stereotipo di
una donna over 60 che beve la birra con
tutte quelle che sono le caratteristiche
che vi ho detto poco fa quindi per
chiudere arrivò al punto e volevo trarre
solo una conclusione insieme a voi e poi
mi piacerebbe sapere se siete d'accordo
allora sicuramente oggi lavorare e
abbattere gli stereotipi di razza è
molto difficile perché lo stiamo vedendo
poi dappertutto no e quindi questo mi
permette cioè mi premette e mi permette
di dire che in effetti è va al di là del
concetto di ristretti stereotipo quello
di razze di genere però abbiamo una cosa
importante anzi brand hanno una cosa
importante che sono una risorsa che è
legata al dato quindi se i dati usati in
modo corretto per veicolare delle
campagne pubblicitarie con all'interno
degli stereotipi sono corretti e giusti
allora chiaramente il brand avrà tutta
la libertà di poterlo fare in modo molto
autonomo e soprattutto
corretto questo è un po il il finale
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]